-Kate Upton, thank you
for being here.
Thank you for playing along
with Ken as well,
earlier in our game.
You've met Ken before.
You worked with him before.
-Yes. Yeah, I was
on his first photo shoot.
So obviously I taught him
everything I know.
-Yeah.
-About modeling.
-Of course, yeah.
-I was a great mentor.
-What was it like working with
Ken on a photo shoot?
-Oh, it was so great.
I mean, he is so funny
in the shots,
but then behind the scenes he's
like, "Oh, my God, I'm so sorry.
I'm a physician.
I shouldn't be holding it
like a pool noodle."
But I was like,
"You just got to lean in,"
and that's why he looks so sexy.
[ Laughter ]
Holding up,
with that pool noodle.
-It doesn't make any sense until
you see this photo.
Here's a photo of Ken and Kate.
See if you can tell
the difference, who's who.
-It's hard to tell.
-Ken is --
[ Laughter ]
What is he doing?
He's lost his -- He's absolutely
lost his -- He's lost his mind.
[ Laughter ]
He's lost his mind.
-And they kept being like,
"Don't --"
-"Don't look at me."
-"Don't look at him.
Don't look at him."
And he was, like,
fully into that noodle.
-How have you been?
I'm sorry to make you remember
those memories.
How have you been?
Talk to me about Strong4Me.
You guys are growing, expanding.
-Yes. I'm so excited because,
you know,
we're all about
inside-out health.
So we're expanding into
a full wellness brand,
and next we're going to tackle
mental wellness,
which I think is so important.
It's not just about working out.
It's also about staying
mentally healthy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's great.
It's taken a while, but it's
actually happened pretty fast
if you think about it because
when we talked about this
years ago when you thought about
this idea and started it,
but good.
-I know.
The community keeps growing,
and it's just so awesome to hear
everyone's stories
and keep the positive
inspiration going.
-You said
that your daughter Genevieve
is an inspiration to you.
-Yes. She's the cutest.
-Look at this little nugget.
-Well, she's 14 months now.
I learned that moms
have to say the months.
-You say the months? Yeah.
-That's what moms do.
-She's so cute.
If she wanted to go into
modeling, would you allow her?
Would you say yes?
-I mean, we're all about passion
in our family.
So if she feels really
passionate about anything,
you know, I know Justin and I
will fully support her with
whatever she wants to do.
And if it's modeling,
I have a few tips.
I mean --
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. Yeah, you had a pretty --
-I did mentor Ken so...
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
She doesn't want to end up
in that direction at all. Yeah.
I saw somewhere that you were
learning jiu-jitsu.
Are you still into that?
-Oh, my God.
I'm obsessed with jiu-jitsu.
I just earned my first stripe
and I --
-Now, how does that work,
the stripes?
-So, you get your belt,
and then you earn three stripes,
and you go to the next color.
So I just got my first one,
and the test is so hard,
and you learn all these
different submissions,
how to break someone's arm,
how to pop the shoulder out,
how to choke them out,
and they test you.
How many chokes do you know?
[ Laughter ]
You know, and I --
I was so into it.
I would practice everywhere,
and my test was right after
the World Series and --
-And you passed?
-Yeah.
Well, I was practicing,
you know, on Justin,
on his whole family,
my mother-in-law.
-He's in the World Series.
What are you talking about?
-Well, he would only let me
practice on him --
-Your mother-in-law.
Oh, my gosh.
What's wrong with you?
Why are you taking jiu-jitsu?
-You know, 'cause I want to
beat someone up.
[ Laughter ]
-No, you don't. Come on.
-I just want to know how.
I just want to know how.
-Are you flipping people
around and --
-Yeah.
-Jiu-jitsu's like MMA type of
stuff, right?
-Yeah. Yep, yep.
-Yeah.
-There's part boxing, jiu-jitsu.
-Everything.
-Yep.
-So right now you're flipping
people around.
-Yes.
-You go to a place --
-Actually, I was --
I accidentally --
I was showing Justin,
and I accidentally flipped him
in our kitchen.
-What?
-And his foot hit, like,
the corner of our island, and he
really just hammed that up.
It was like a cut this big,
and he was like, "I'm injured!
"I'm injured!"
I was like, "Calm down.
It's not your right arm."
[ Laughter ]
-Could you teach me a move
and all of us a move in case?
-Yes, yes.
Of course, of course. Okay.
-Alright, let's do it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So, technically
I only have one stripe.
I'm not, like, safety certified.
-Okay.
-But it's fine.
Just make sure to tap
if you feel, like, panicked.
-Tap if I feel panicked?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
'Cause I don't know my limits.
Okay, so,
if you're coming at me --
-Okay, so wait. First of all,
why are you already like this?
-Because I'm in my fight stance.
[ Laughter ]
-But if you're doing this,
that means that you want me
to come at you?
If you're like, "Hey, Jimmy,"
what do you want me to do?
I go, "What's your problem?"
Of course,
I'm going to run to you
and jump in your arms
if you do that.
So, alright, so you do that
and I -- What do I do?
Like, do you want me
to attack you?
-Yeah, just if you were
walking like, yeah.
Come like you're attacking me.
-What are you gonna do?
Can you just tell me
what you're going to do?
[ Laughter ]
Just tell me what you're gonna
do because I don't
want have to --
What if my instincts fight back?
You know what I'm saying?
-It's okay. I can take you down.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God.
And by the way,
you probably can.
Alright. Alright.
So, I'm walking?
-Okay, I'm going to do
the rear naked choke hold.
-Say it again.
-The rear naked choke.
-We're doing
the rear naked choke hold?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Let's do it, man.
I mean, let's go for it, man.
At this point.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Honey, turn the channel.
-Okay, so walk towards me.
-Okay, just walk towards you.
-Yep, and then I would just --
-Oh, man. Oh, man.
Alright, that's good.
[ Laughter ]
-No, you got to tap out
with your hand.
-Oh, I thought
you meant tapping --
I already tapped out. I was
tapping out. I was tapping.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That was a good hold.
How do you do that?
You press really --
-Yeah, yeah.
-You pass out?
I'm really passing out
a little bit.
What were you doing?
-Yeah, it takes -- it takes
12 seconds to fully pass out.
-Wait, how many seconds
did you do that?
[ Laughter ]
-I wasn't even --
As soon as you tapped,
I stopped.
Even the tap dancing.
-That was like a --
[ Laughter ]
That was a five-second
tap dance.
You did it like seven --
Alright.
Here, it's happening again.
Kate Upton, everyone.
Check out Strong4Me Fitness.
Old Dominion
performs for us next.
Stick around, everybody.
Come on back. Wow.